All right. Initially we have--I cut 9.
So these are the cuts that I made and just to show that it's still connected.
There's a little bit of plastic that goes around without passing through any cuts
but there should be no loops--so every little region here that a turtle could get trapped in
we have a cut in it and in fact, a series of cuts that gets you to the outside.
So this region here exits out through here, here and out.
This region say you exit here, here and out, region then run out, run out, this one here and out.
Every region now opens up and then some other region will actually close up.
So how many cuts did I make and I'm going to say--so did you.
There are many, many ways of doing these cuts, but I still think you'll had 14.